en juillet dernier dans le vaucluse ils
sont allemands français ou anglais
chaque été ils débarquent par cars
entiers pour visiter les terres de
catherine une centaine d'hectares
qu'elle partage avec ses frères donc ici
nous sommes dans la propriété de mes
aïeuls je suis une cinquième génération
mais des deux branches
si ces touristes sont venus de loin pour
écouter des histoires de famille
c'est pour elle la lavande l'emblème de
toute la région avec mais ma grand mère
et les enfants y monter dans la montagne
et récolté la lavande sauvage qu'il dise
il est sur place avec un alambic
itinérant donc mon grand-père
commercialiser son essence de lavande au
parfumeur et pour et aux pharmaciens
fier de ses racines catherine partage
avec ses visiteurs de siècles de culture
familiale
les touristes sont ici comme au musée
donc c'est plein de sons sont très gais
ya eu environ quinze habitants et on
arrachait tout le champ c'était un champ
de collection ou en aviez où on avait
différentes sortes et on leur fera petit
à petit un musée avec ses produits
dérivés
maintenant vous allez tester et goûter
sirop de lavande et les petits biscuits
avec de la confiture de laval la lavande
à déguster ou à boire une découverte
surprenante
donc c'est une infusion de fleurs de
lavande avec du citron et c'est vraiment
dégoûtant
un goût à apprivoiser vraiment goût de
la bande
ce projet très intéressant on va ont
rapporté en allemagne
c'est vrai que le traditionnel c'est les
petits sachets de lavande qu'on met dans
l'armoire
donc ça c'est les choses connues l'on
peut dans le camp mais là plus froid on
peut faire d'autres choses dans les
toilettes la vente saucisse au prix de
la visite 7 euros sans compter les
produits dérivés acheté à la boutique un
moyen pour catherine d'arrondir ses fins
de mois
car si autrefois la lavande permettait à
sa famille de vivre confortablement
ce n'est plus le cas un paradoxe quand
on sait que ces dernières années cette
petite fleur bleue a connu un formidable
succès commercial dans les cosmétiques
pour ses propriétés relaxantes
en aromathérapie pour ses vertus
antiseptiques et cicatrisante la lavande
et surtout la star du rayon entretien où
elle parfume lessive assouplissant ou
encore eau de javel
pourtant la production de la banque
française n'a jamais été aussi basse
alors pourquoi leur bleu de provence est
il en crise
à quelle concurrence doit-il faire face
y at il des arnaques
[Musique]
première surprise ce que l'on prend pour
de la lavande n'en est pas toujours à
grignan en drôme provençale premiers
jours de récolte pour laurent grand beau
je comprends pour la journée en ce début
juillet laurent entame trois semaines de
cours sur son exploitation de 22
hectares
[Musique]
une couleur une fleur qui ressemble à la
lavande mais qui n'en est pas il s'agit
en fait de l'avant dans une plantes plus
résistantes met au parfum à moins
subtile une version moins nobles de la
lavande a pas une grosse année ça soit
au plan il suffit de savoir compter
quand on prend un épi en fait on compte
les étages
airwide à 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 que si
l'un à 10 il ya des années on peut
refaire 13 à voir mais ramené à
l'hectare
je présume ce ne sera pas une grosse
saison malheureusement après on les
années se suivent et se ressemblent par
laurent cultive aussi la vigne mais il
tire l'essentiel de ses revenus du
lavandin il ne faut rien perdre plus que
la qualité c'est la quantité qui prime
on a la paille et on a toutes les fleurs
qu'on a laissé des fleurs qui vont faire
lui l'essentiel est là pas que vous
aurez pour le moment on n'a pas le la
machine on n'a pas encore trouvé le
procédé qui nous permet donc de séparer
mais bon on y réfléchir mais bon le
conseil n'est pas encore fini de séparer
donc une tige voilà de la fleur voilà
tout est décidé voilà la tige donc
l'affiché verte plus la fleur pour que
c'est vrai que sur une remorque comme ça
la grosse partie du volume c'est de la
tige
le principal intérêt du lavandin c'est
son rendement
as porté à desserrer il est six fois
supérieur à celui de la lavande
c'est pourquoi aujourd'hui 90% des
champs bleus que l'on voit en provence
sont en réalité des champs de lavande un
première visite de l'été à la
distillerie pour laurent c'est ici qu'il
va se faire une idée de son chiffre
d'affaires de l'année
ce qu'il vend ce ne sont pas les fleurs
mais l'huile essentielle qu'il en
extrait la distillation prend une heure
et demie la remorque est placé sous la
chaudière puis on injecte de la vapeur
d'eau il suffit ensuite d'attendre que
l'huile se détache de l'eau là au milieu
c'est donc le lot avec huiles
essentielles et donc je le faire
déborder
là je ferme l'arrivée d'eau donc
toujours nommés membres à ce tour est
entier et pas faire augmenter les temps
voilà une dernière étape délicate et
voici enfin le précieux liquide
la cellule essentielle c'est en fait on
va en parler sur les marchés où t'en
vends donc aux négociants c'est cette
prévu là c'est ma récolte c'est pour ça
que j'ai travaillé douze années cette
huile essentielle de lavandin servira à
parfumer des lessives assouplissant et
autres produits d'entretien - même se
présenter 10 kg en gros présenter dès
qu'ils auront sur 8000 m ça fait en gros
du 100 kg ha à peu près la tentation
était un plus âgé en bout de ligne c'est
moyen orient moyenne plus laurent van
son huile essentielle 17 euros le kilo
quatre fois moins chère que celle de
lavande
une aubaine pour les lessiviers mais pas
seulement même la parfumerie fine jusque
là chasse gardée de la lavande est
aujourd'hui gagné par le la vendant à
versailles l'osmothèque un conservatoire
de senteurs conçu par jean pierre léaud
qui officiait comme né dans une illustre
maison de parfumerie
or notre cerveau à la cave
il collectionne les fragrances comme il
collectionnera les grands crus certaines
recettes datent du premier siècle sur
les étagères 1800 flacon dont beaucoup
affichent le même ingrédient voilà on
par exemple voilà vous avez donc une
baisse ou un vendeur de leur lait d'une
très vieille
la vendre là il ya aussi un petit peu de
lavande alors voilà je tombe par hasard
dessus arômes 3 ça ne dit rien du tout
c'est une demande comment c'est vraiment
la vente d'avant d'une très belle la
ronde
vous avez surtout azzaro est encore
connus viennent est numéro un des ventes
de produits pour hommes dont 4 0 pour
hommes vous avez dans la même catégorie
vous avez déjà vous avez égoïste
platinum de chanel ces projets là ce
sont des produits quand même à
destination essentiellement masculine 9
parfum masculin sur 10 contiennent de la
lavande
d'ailleurs c'est à elle que jean-pierre
les audois l'un des plus grands succès
de sa carrière donné l'eau de sport de
lacoste
pourtant aujourd'hui il se désole de
voir la lavande remplacé par le lavandin
vous avez beaucoup de gens qui ont été
mises de l'avant d'un parfait nous mêmes
à la percée vers l'avant mais ce n'est
pas pour moi c'est pas un critère de
qualité
je trouve qu'il ya un côté beaucoup plus
vulgaire si l'on peut dire dans le
lavandin par contre de lavande est plus
intéressant ce d'abord moins cher parce
qu'il faut regarder le prix on consacre
moins d'argent pour le tournage d'un
savons que pour une eau de toilette et
puis ce côté qui ont frais etc ça
résiste plus à la chaleur si on peut
dire et donc vous avez quand même d'un
noble sommes concurrencés par le
lavandin la lavande de provence doit
aussi faire face à une menace qui vient
de beaucoup plus loin grâce la capitale
de la parfumerie
on y trouve les plus importants
négociants du secteur comme charabot
cette société achète des matières
premières pour le compte de parfumeurs
et de lessiviers les huiles essentielles
de rose de bergamote et de lavande sont
revendus en l'état ou déjà assemblés à
la tête de la division matières
premières josé adrian on jouait pas ce
week end
depuis quelques années quand la récolte
est moins bonne en france
il a pris une habitude alors montrez moi
vos échantillons recourir à des
importations
je crois qu'aujourd'hui le fait d'avoir
des lavandes étrangères nous permet de
faire face à la marche est la nôtre la
vente semaine pierre haski a rien de
pire que de ne pas pouvoir soumettre
d'échantillons quand un client ou
demande de l'immeuble avant josé adrian
achètent parfois jusqu'à 35% de sa
lavande à l'étranger et pas seulement en
bulgarie
allégis il s'approvisionne aussi en
ukraine en moldavie et même en chine des
pays qui se sont convertis à la lavande
dans les années 70 si au début les prix
faisait la différence
ce n'est plus le cas aujourd'hui en
france ou dans les pays de l'est c'est
70 euros le kg d'huile essentielle il
existe pourtant une variété de lavande
beaucoup moins cher sauf que celle-ci ne
pousse pas dans les champs on a un
client sur l'indonésie puis un savonnier
qui voudraient de lavande et qui
voudraient de lavande poteau
moi je dirais en dessous des 7 8 euros
en tout dix en tout cas dans ce cas là
une re coureurs il s'agit d'une la vente
chimiques fabriqués en laboratoire
alors une reconstitution c'est à dire
que dans une huile essentielle on a
plusieurs constituants qu'on peut
synthétiser chimiquement par le partir
du pétrole
et dans ce cas là quand on sait qu'une
avance à peu près deux tiers de linalol
et das tête de l'ina lille on les trouve
sur le marché c'est une molécule
synthétique et on peut donc les
assemblées avec d'autres pour avoir un
profil de l'huile essentielle de lavande
fine de l'allant dimanche à retrouver
oui tout à fait encore baisser si on may
en rajoute du solvant voilà seulement
neutre qu'on peut couper moitié vous
allez avoir du jeu 4 5 euros mais bon
c'est pas s'attendre à voir quelque
chose de très puissant de très riches
mais c'est une caricature et il ya des
démarches et un produit de synthèse qui
n'a plus rien de naturel
on s'assied josé pourra satisfaire son
client indonésien avec cet ersatz de
lavande à 8 euros deux fois moins cher
que du lavandin est dix fois moins que
de la lavande fine c'est quand même
fleury le fruité de un très bon bon
travail ouais il ya quand même le coeur
de la note qui est là et c'est un très
bon rapport qualité prix pour certaines
applications plutôt en parfumerie
fonctionnel et c'est tout à fait
honorables comme qualité voilà donc
c'est une fausse c'est une pause l'avant
alors fausse vraie je note les notes
lavande
entre la concurrence de la lavande
bulgares ou chinoises et l'apparition
des produits de synthèse bien meilleur
marché les producteurs français se
sentent menacés francis vidal est en
quelque sorte le gardien du temple de la
lavande de provence
cet agriculteur a créé une appellation
d'origine contrôlée
la vente de haute provence bonjour à
tous on va ce soir il rejoint catherine
l'agricultrice qui joue les guides
touristiques ainsi que quelques autres
lavandiculteurs tous sont des puristes
parmi eux ce jour-là il y à aussi robert
evans un producteur australien que
catherine a rencontrée lors d'un de ses
voyages il vend de l'huile essentielle
mais commercialise aussi sa lavande sous
des formes moins orthodoxes les
lavandiculteurs reste méfiant d'autant
que l'australien a l'air de s'y
connaître
il possède la plus grande exploitation
de l'hémisphère sud leeuwin je vis en
fait à sydney mais mon exploitation et
en tasmanie et dites moi pourquoi êtes
vous venu en france pour observer les
meilleures pratiques et voir comment les
experts cultiver leurs champs
l'australien et diplomates
il accepte même de s'exposer à la
critique fine une comparaison on va pas
faire un jury m'ont alors se contenter
de faire une comparaison entre les deux
sans hésiter il soumet sa production au
nez de ces provençaux intransigeant
notre pépite
comparez vous verrez c'est beaucoup plus
on râle ça comme ça mais c'est bien
aussi
il en faut plus que ça pour m'inquiéter
on est doué dans le berceau de la
lavande ce fait je veux dire ça change
tout je pense en australie sont pas
encore là plus encore que la lavande
étrangères depuis quelques années c'est
surtout la vente de synthèse qui
préoccupe ses agriculteurs
je préfère mieux voir un produit comme
ça que ça soit australien je dirais même
chinois ou bulgares que d'avoir un
produit chimique on appelle la lande ça
pour moi c'est l'horreur
ce que j'ai trouvé une eau de toilette
marqué naturel lavande sauvage de haute
provence et donc composition derrière
parfait s'il s'agissait bien de l'avant
naturel
il y aurait marqué huiles essentielles
maintenant notre défense au niveau de
l'inflation c'est plutôt contre ces
produits chimiques sur l'allée si on
remarquer la vanille anata ça n'est pas
et c'est pas normal ça
[Musique]
pour ces provençaux la synthèse serait
même en passe d'enterrer leurs bleus
pourtant en magasin les marques
continuent de jouer sur le naturel en
affichant des brins de lavande ou des
chants move sur les emballages
mais qu'y a t'il vraiment dans ces
flacons aux couleurs très affirmé à
bruxelles au siège européen de procter &
gamble ces jours de tests les employés
passe la serpillière et font la lessive
ici il y a des dizaines de machines a
lancé et 15 salle de bain à nettoyer
avant que la parfumeuse en chef ne
pointe son nez
aujourd'hui catherine canal fait évoluer
le parfum de sa gamme lavande
[Musique]
l'objectif est de moderniser cette
l'avant c'est notre la vente qui est
déjà qui est assez classique mais ici
c'est une lave on a fait plus
résiduelles mais le coup le fond boisé
en vrai trop présent et ça que ça ça
pousse le côté racé de l'avant mais ça
donne à côté pas très propre donc
finalement cette direction là qui va
révéler chez catherine ne parle pas de
lavande mais de notes lavande
car d'abord elle utilise du lavandin et
dans ces produits
il n'y a pas une seule goutte d'huile
essentielle de lavande ya pas une
l'avant je crois qu'il ya un concept la
ronde avec plein de notes différentes la
note la vendre parce qu'on veut quand on
dit la vente c'est une note la vente
c'est l'odeur de la vente
finalement vous quand on compare les
huiles essentielles c'est vrai qu'à une
différence à la vente final une note
beaucoup plus floral alors que la bande
à une autre beaucoup plus qu'on ferait
beaucoup plusieurs basse et dans notre
île de parfumerie ces photos déjà wanda
pour différentes raisons pour des
raisons de coût et des raisons de
disponibilité sur le marché également du
lavandin donc et aussi de la synthèse
même si catherine pas très à l'aise
préfère insister sur le côté naturel
il ya des ingrédients naturels dans le
parfum
ici il ya une grande quantité d'huile
essentielle de lavande heures mais bon
ça je peux pas vous dire parce que les
formules de personnes seulement
financière mais c'est quand même c'est
quand même presque plus d'un quart de
un quart des parfums et les français
nous avons des produits lavande parfumé
essentiellement avec de la synthèse
c'est légal à condition de le préciser
sur l'emballage
mais tous les fabricants se donne t'il
cette peine nous avons voulu le vérifier
en faisant analyser cinq articles
choisis au hasard
uniquement des produits qui n'affiche
pas la mention parfums de synthèse
quelques jours plus tard denis rothen
docteur en biochimie nous décrypte les
résultats plutôt troublant sur les cinq
produits et kim ont été analysés en fait
les 5 contient des substances de
synthèse ou démis sa thèse parmi ces
cinq produits de ont retenu son
attention
d'abord une huile essentielle en
principe sont pour son naturel
vous avez surtout ici un énorme pic qui
est du solvant une nuit essentielles
pures ne doit pas contenir de soro donc
ça veut dire que même s'il ya peut-être
des produits naturels dans cette huile
essentielle en revanche et année là que
pour aromatiser un solvant 70% c'est du
solvant le gros problème moi que je
voudrais ajouter quand même avec cette
huile essentielle c'est que si vous
lisez dans un magazine que la lavande a
des propriétés sédatives et que vous en
mettez sur votre oreiller pour mieux
dormir
si vous mettez ça c'est votre oreiller
vous aller respirer du solvant toute la
nuit puisque c'est principalement du
solvant et que par conséquent au
lendemain matin vous allez avoir mal à
la tête et vous n'aurez pas du tout
l'effet que vous attendiez deuxième
produit s'est assoupli son qui sort sur
la mode de l'aromathérapie
non il n'ya pas d'huiles essentielles
dans le produit numéro un
effectivement c'est assez étonnant parce
que ce produit revendiquent de lui
essentielles naturelles de l'ylang ylang
et de la vendre mais en même temps si
vous savez lire la liste des ingrédients
c'est pas indiqué qui a de lui essentiel
dedans donc comment peut-on parler
d'aromathérapie quand on n'utilise pas
lui est essentielle
la question reste en suspens en tout cas
on peut pas le faire normalement
le comble c'est que la synthèse et
peut-être l'avenir de la lavande
[Musique]
car une grave menace plane sur les
champs de haute provence au pied du mont
ventoux
michel blanc vite avec depuis 2003 il
est lavandiculteurs mais s'occupe aussi
de 300 brebis c'est son petit plaisir ça
là c'est le métier d'éleveur c'est la
passion qu autre chose parce que si vous
la vague comme ses parents l'avaient
fait avant lui michel tire l'essentiel
de ses revenus de la lavande mais en ce
mois de mai il le sait déjà
sa récolte est compromise ça c'est une
plante qui était en train de crever du
dépérissement le dépérissement une
maladie qui depuis quatre ans des cimes
70% des cultures de lavande et
commencent à s'attaquer aux l'avant dans
les traces blanches la sas et des
présents acea
c'est ce qui atteste de la présence de
la cicadelle c'est une espèce de petit
cigale la toute petite de 2 mm c'est le
vecteur de la maladie
celle qui transmet le phytoplasme d'une
plante à l'autre
la petite cigale n'épargne aucune
lavande
elle transmet la maladie la plante se
dessèche et meurt à petit feu
aucun traitement n'est possible
tout a été arraché serait venu à la
quinzaine de sa toutes les parcelles là
derrière l'enfant de ce côté c'est
michel cultiver 40 hectares en 2005
il ne lui reste plus que 15 presque
trois fois moins
ce sont tous des jeunes plants à peine
mur pour la récolte
rien à voir avec ce qu'il a connu dans
son enfance second procès on peut
toujours rêver qu'un jour ça revient à
l'époque le seul souci c'était de se
dire bon est ce qu'on m'a tout vendre
est ce qu'on va pouvoir avoir une
récolte
problème il y a encore quatre ans sa
femme laurence travailler à plein temps
sur l'exploitation
elle s'occupait des fleurs et des
bouquets la principale source de revenus
du couple
si je me suis retrouvé dans les champs
début juillet à couper 30 bouquets de
lavande sur quatre en géant
d'habitude on en fait au moins 300 sur
une rangée quoi donc j'ai décidé de
s'arrêter
non j'ai vite parce que ça me démoralise
michel ne baisse pas les bras
ils replante chaque année de nouvelles
parcelles l'une d'elles est expérimental
des chercheurs y ont installé
différentes variétés sélectionnées dans
la nature pour leur tolérance à la
maladie ce jour là ils viennent
constater leur évolution
bon je vais vous voir pour voir un peu
comment ça se passe et leurs parcelles
c'est vrai que là de ce côté c'est pas
mais vous avez quelques plombs
dépérissants ouais c'est pas très
encourageant si on prend une une pousse
une jolie plante et là on voit très bien
que l avait pas envoyé il ya un retard
végétatif on peut pas se tromper sur la
taille des ajoncs même h
les parcelles de michel sont scrutés
deux fois par an sur le terrain les
chercheurs prélève des échantillons pour
repérer les plans les plus résistants et
les croisés ils ont ainsi obtenu trois
nouvelles variétés
mais michel n'est pas franchement
convaincu
[Musique]
dans certains secteurs ça marche à peu
près mais mais d'autres ça pas marché et
donc nous pour en voir une assurance
d'une récolte future nous en ferons
encore plus quoi il faut être certain
d'avoir des dés de lavande qui alors un
qui puisse résister résister à cette
maladie et 2 qui correspondent aux
marchés dont on a besoin
je crois que c'est juste une question de
temps et pour nous le demande
voilà c'est là on l'a pas trop le temps
semble en effet compter à cause de la
maladie
la production de lavande en france s'est
effondré en cinq ans elle a été divisée
par 3 l'or bleu de provence est en train
de virer au gris